On ne sait pas quel jour on sera tué...
Qui va nous tuer.
Qui va kidnapper nos enfants.
Qui va tuer nos parents,
parce qu'on a travaillé
avec l'armée française.
c'est vrai qu'ils sont considérés
là-bas, comme des traîtres.
Ils sont grillés.
Ils ont tout lâché de leur côté,
si nous on ne leur tend pas la main,
qu’est-ce qu'ils deviennent ?
On n’est pas là pour leur faire du mal,
on est en patrouille.
Aujourd'hui, on a des collègues
qui sont tous menacés
par les talibans et Daesh
à cause de leur collaboration
avec l' armée française.
Ces traducteurs ont risqué
leur vie
aux côtés de soldats français,
voire parfois,
ont permis de sauver la vie
de soldats français.
Il y a une volonté
d'en rapatrier le moins possible
parce qu'on considère
ces auxiliaires d'armée
comme des migrants.
Aujourd'hui qu'on les laisse derrière nous,
c'est scandaleux.
Oui, c'est un scandale d’État.
À partir de la fin de l’année 2001
jusqu’à fin 2012,
la France intervient en Afghanistan
pour combattre les talibans
et lutter contre le terrorisme
aux côtés d’une coalition internationale.
Pour cette mission, les militaires français
ont travaillé avec plus de 800 tarjumans,
des traducteurs afghans,
qui ont toujours voulu être rapatriés,
au même titre que l'armée française.
J’étais encore à l’école
quand j'ai commencé
à travailler avec l’armée française
en 2003 jusqu’à juillet 2012.
J’étais avec l’équipe qui s’appelait Artec.
C’était une équipe d’intervention
sur les attentats, les explosions.
C’était une équipe d’investigation.
J’ai donné 9 ans à l’armée française.
Je travaillais le jour et la nuit
pour l’armée française.
Et travailler avec les troupes étrangères,
c’est toujours un risque.
Les gens ici pensent que ceux
qui ont travaillé avec les armées étrangères
sont des espions.
Ma vie est complètement en danger.
Je ne peux pas aller dehors,
les gens cherchent les interprètes.
Les talibans n’ont pas hésité à exécuter
des membres des familles des traducteurs
et des traducteurs
pour essayer de dissuader les gens
de venir le faire.
Et donc, tous les gens
qui ont été traducteurs
l’ont fait au péril de leur vie,
au péril de la vie de leur famille.
Et depuis le départ de l’armée française
en 2012,
beaucoup de ces traducteurs
ont essayé de se cacher
et ils sont toujours vulnérables.
Certains d’entre eux se retrouvent
régulièrement reconnus,
voient des menaces sur la porte
de leur maison
et certains d’entre eux
ont déjà été tués.
Le 23 juin pendant la nuit,
à 23h15,
j’ai été attaqué par des gens armés.
Il y avait 2 ou 3 personnes
qui étaient armées.
Ils frappaient à la porte,
j'y suis allé pour voir qui c’était.
Les gens parlaient entre eux:
“C'est sa maison”.
Ils ont commencé à tirer.
Ils ont détruit la porte d’entrée de chez moi.
Quelques vitres ont été cassées
mais heureusement, je n’ai pas été touché.
Est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment
d’avoir été abandonné par l’armée
française et l’État français?
Oui, je sens qu’on est abandonnés.
Depuis le départ des Français,
on est dans une situation très dangereuse.
Bien sûr que j’ai peur pour ma vie
et celle de ma famille
parce que je ne veux pas
que mes enfants perdent la vie
à cause de mon travail
avec l’armée française.
La procédure pour délivrer des visas,
je l’ai faite une fois
mais sans raison,
ma demande a été rejetée
par l’ambassade de France.
On est optimistes,
on espère que bientôt,
on pourra avoir notre visa
et sauver notre vie,
celle de nos enfants et de notre famille.
Quand les Français
sont arrivés en Afghanistan,
ils n’avaient aucun relais local.
Ils connaissaient pas ce pays,
ils connaissaient pas les vallées de ce pays
ils connaissaient pas les coutumes,
ils connaissaient pas la culture
donc il a fallu pour les militaires français
être en contact avec des Afghans,
avec des locaux,
et les relais des militaires français,
c’étaient leurs interprètes
donc sans eux, les militaires français
n’étaient rien en Afghanistan.
Du coup, j’ai voulu savoir si des militaires
français ayant servi en Afghanistan
et ayant travaillé
avec des traducteurs locaux
trouvaient ça normal.
Et c’est comme ça que j’ai rencontré
l’adjudant-chef Jean-François.
Bon je suis retraité…
maintenant.
J’étais instructeur de tir
et instructeur armement.
J'ai été déployé en Afghanistan.
Je suis arrivé en mai 2011.
On devait former soit des soldats,
soit des cadres
et dans notre mission,
on était aidés par des traducteurs,
les tarjumans.
On n’est pas là pour leur faire du mal,
on est en patrouille.
Sur place,
ils peuvent apaiser des tensions
puisqu’ils vont aller
au devant des populations,
expliquer ce que font les militaires,
ce que fait la force ici.
Ils ont un rôle important,
c’est vraiment l’interface.
- Est-ce que vous les considérez
comme des frères d’armes
quand vous êtes en opération?
Bah tout à fait. Pour moi,
c’était comme des soldats.
Ils étaient dans mon équipe,
c’était comme mes soldats.
Ouais, des frères d’armes,
bien sûr.
Il y a des secteurs d’ailleurs
où c’était dangereux,
ils étaient armés.
On sait qu’ils sont dans la vallée.
Il ne peut pas dire le contraire.
Parfois, ce qu’ils faisaient c’était,
pour les renseignements français,
de l’écoute.
Non, il n'y en a pas ici.
Ça veut dire que ce sont des gens qui sont
responsables de la mort de militants talibans
et que les talibans n’hésiteront pas
à exécuter comme traîtres,
comme responsables de la mort
de certains de leurs combattants.
Donc ce sont des gens
qui sont aujourd’hui
dans une très, très grande
vulnérabilité.
C’est vrai qu'ils sont considérés
là-bas, comme des traîtres.
Ils sont grillés.
Ils ont tout lâché de leur côté,
si nous on ne leur tend pas la main,
qu’est-ce qu'ils deviennent ?
Et après six mois d’opération
sur le terrain,
l’adjudant-chef Jean-François
se lie d'amitié
avec son traducteur Arifulla,
mais la France décide
de quitter le pays.
La France se retire,
il y a un premier groupe qui est rapatrié.
Donc je pensais que, tout naturellement,
ça allait suivre.
Surtout le cas de Ari,
un francophile comme lui.
Et puis, plus rien.
C’est là qu’on commence à s’inquiéter.
D’ailleurs, à chaque fois
qu’il y avait un attentat,
j’appelais, je demandais si…
On avait gardé contact avec Skype.
C’est là que j’ai été voir
à droite, à gauche.
J’ai essayé d’intervenir
avec mes petits moyens.
Et finalement, il est arrivé en 2018.
Mais lui, il s’était souvenu
de ce que j’avais dit :
“Tu te pointes n’importe quand,
on te récupère."
Et c’était une putain
de bonne nouvelle.
Ouais, je sais pas,
je me suis intéressé à Ari,
peut-être que j’ai fait
une fixette sur lui.
Je m’étais dit:
"Toi, tu boiras un coup en Bourgogne."
Ça fait peur... Ils se sont dit,
faire venir des Afghans en France.
Alors que c’étaient des gens
qui ont travaillé avec des Français,
qui ont travaillé
avec l’armée en plus,
qui ont une certaine culture.
Je trouvais ça injuste.
C’est donnant-donnant.
Lui, il a donné pour la France,
il faut qu’il reçoive.
La trahison qui est faite
à ces traducteurs afghans
est d’autant plus forte
que lorsque ces traducteurs
se sont engagés
aux côtés des militaires français,
il leur a été dit qu’en cas
de problème,
ils pourraient venir en France.
Ça a été une des manières
utilisées pour inciter des gens
à venir être traducteurs
et être guides.
Il y a ici une politique d’État
qui trahit des gens
qui se sont battus pour lui.
Sauf que cette promesse,
elle n’était pas écrite noir sur blanc
dans le contrat des traducteurs.
Et lorsque la France commence à se retirer
de l’Afghanistan à partir de fin 2011,
plusieurs centaines
de traducteurs afghans
ont fait une demande de visa
qu’ils n’ont pas obtenu
parce que le ministère
de l’Intérieur a décidé
de mettre en place des quotas
très stricts.
Nous, on a découvert
que Manuel Valls,
à l’époque ministre de l’Intérieur, dit :
“Nous, on en rapatrie 35
sur les 800 qu’on a embauchés.
Vous me choisissez les 35 meilleurs,
ceux qui présenteront le moins
de problèmes d’intégration en France
et ceux qui sont le plus en danger,
vous me les rapatriez."
Et au cours de cette enquête,
les journalistes Quentin Müller et Brice Andlauer
découvrent aussi des échanges de mails
entre l’attaché de défense de l’ambassade
de France à Kaboul et ses collègues
où on peut voir en fait que les traducteurs
ont été classés avec des appréciations telles que
“plus de 60 ans, famille nombreuse”
ou encore “semble bien islamiste”.
Il y a une volonté d’en rapatrier le moins
possible parce qu’on considère
ces auxiliaires d’armée
comme des migrants,
comme des chiffres en moins
sur le budget du ministère du Logement,
sur le budget du ministère
de la Défense…
Donc il y a un mépris pour ces gens-là.
Pourtant en 2012, Jean-Yves Le Drian,
alors ministre de la Défense
et aujourd’hui ministre
des Affaires étrangères,
assurait que la France aiderait
les traducteurs afghans.
La France ne doit pas abandonner
ses collaborateurs,
quelle que soit leur situation,
et ceux qui sont le plus à risque,
trouveront en France l’accueil
qu’ils méritent.
Bah 7 ans plus tard, l’accueil de certains
traducteurs afghans
est en réalité loin d’être à la hauteur.
Sur Twitter, un supporter du FC Nantes
m’a parlé des Sattari,
une famille de traducteurs afghans
arrivés en juillet 2019,
et qui depuis, est baladée
d’hôtel 115 en hôtel 115.
Je viens d’arriver à la gare de Saint-Nazaire
où je rejoins Frédéric,
c’est un gars de Twitter
qui a aidé la famille Sattari
quand il a appris qu’elle devait quitter
son hôtel 115 de Nantes
et qui les a aidés à s’installer
à Saint-Nazaire.
- Charles, enchanté.
- Enchanté.
Alors toi, comment tu t’es retrouvé
à aider la famille Sattari ?
En fait, j’ai découvert leur histoire
au travers du réseau social Twitter.
Et leur histoire m’a touché.
Et en plus, ça se passe dans ma ville
donc difficile de détourner les yeux
quand on lit un récit,
une histoire pareille.
J’ai un compte qui regroupe
une communauté de fans
nantais, entre autres,
assez importante
donc des gens
qui habitent Nantes.
Sous un hashtag
qu’on utilise, qui est :
#onestnantesputain
ça veut dire que face à l’adversité,
on peut tout faire.
On peut renverser tous les défis.
- Ok, donc là, on est arrivés, c’est ça?
- Là, on est à l’hôtel.
Allez, on y va.
- Hello !
Comment tu vas?
Comment tu vas Abdul ?
Bonjour madame.
Do not modify/translate ! ||{"type":"Subtitle","videoTrackIdx":8,"id":"1575654217678","PropertieIndex":0,"displayProperty":"Text"}
Combien de fois vous avez dû partir
depuis que vous êtes arrivés?
- 1, 2, 3, c’est la quatrième fois.
- 4 fois en seulement 3 mois?
- Oui, en 3 mois.
Quand on a atterri en France,
je m’attendais à ce que
l’armée française soit là
et nous souhaite la bienvenue
parce qu’on a travaillé dur pour elle.
On a fait le même travail,
on était aussi des cibles dans les combats,
en face des mêmes ennemis.
- Que faites-vous de vos journées ?
- Je m’occupe de ma femme
parce qu’elle ne peut pas se déplacer,
elle est paralysée.
Je dois faire attention à mes enfants.
On aimerait apprendre le français
parce que je pense
que c’est la priorité.
L'une des choses les plus difficiles
pour la famille, c’est l’ennui.
Ils restent toute la journée
dans leur chambre
ils n’ont rien à faire,
ils n’ont pas d’activité,
pas de cours de français
donc il n’y a aucune prise
en charge pour les aider à s’intégrer
ou à reprendre le cours
d’une vie normale
et s'il n’y avait pas les bénévoles
pour leur filer un coup de main,
bah ils seraient complètement
livrés à eux-mêmes.
Vous avez vu, on a perdu hier?
- Notre club.
- De football ?
- Oui, on a perdu.
Tu les as aussi convertis au foot?
Bah ouais, ils s’intéressent.
Mais ils adorent le foot !
- Vous aimez le foot ?
- Oui !
- Oui, j’adore le foot
et l’équipe de Barcelone.
Real Madrid.
- L’équipe du FC Nantes !
Paris !
- Ah non. Pas Paris.
- Pas Paris ?
- Non, c'est pas possible.
Impossible.
- Là ça va pas le faire.
- Ça le fera pas là.
On ira à un match au stade
ensemble.
- Un autre match ?
- Oui, un autre match.
- Si Dieu le veut.
Qu’est-ce qui t’a le plus surpris
aujourd’hui
dans ce qu’ils ont pu
nous raconter ?
Je les ai pas vus depuis 3-4 jours.
C’est de voir la meilleure mine,
ils ont bonne mine.
Je pense qu’ils ont retrouvé de l’espoir.
Je pense que ça y est,
la rencontre entre ces gens
et puis la France,
ça y est, elle est faite.
Et c’est ça qui je pense
nous importait avec les copains.
C’était de leur montrer que la France,
c’était autre chose
qu’une miteuse chambre d’hôtel.
Allez...
- Mon ami, merci.
Bonne journée.
Merci, au revoir.
J’espère que tout va s’arranger
pour vous
et que vous serez
bien reçus en France.
Merci beaucoup pour votre intérêt, monsieur !
Merci beaucoup.
Depuis 2012, la France en a accueilli
environ 250.
Elle fait figure de mauvaise élève
à l’échelle européenne.
À titre de comparaison,
l’Allemagne en a rapatrié 760.
Si ce reportage vous a interressé,
vous pouvez aussi regarder
le documentaire que j'ai réalisé
sur la guerre en Afghanistan
en cliquant juste ici et n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner à la chaine Youtube de Brut,
à très vite.